Samuel leaves here on the property
investor and landlord and in this video
I'm going to talk about the two kinds of
tenants that you need to avoid these two
types of tenants will ruin your life
crush your dreams make your children
starve and ruin your business who are
the kind of tenants I'm talking about
and how can you avoid having tenants
like this in your house first kind of
tenant is someone who doesn't pay the
rent kind of obvious right so I want to
doesn't pay the rent there are the
continually pay it right or they just
don't pay at all terrible kind of
tenants I'm going to talk about how to
avoid those tenants how to keep the red
flags that come up so you know they're
going to pay their rent and also if you
do have a bad tenant that's not paying
work how to evict them properly as well
second thing is these kind of tenants
are worse than the tenants that don't
pay rent these are the tenants who trash
your property you do not want those kind
of tenants if you have a tenant that
trashes your house it could cost you
tens of thousands of pounds so I mean
and I've had this I've had both kind of
tenants but leave it on I've been in
property for over a decade I've got a
lot of houses and I've got a lot more
tenants than I even have houses because
sometimes I rent them out by the room
and I've experienced some bad tenants
some amazing tenants but I want to share
with you the pitfalls of these two
tenants how to avoid them here's an
interesting thing a bad tenant can only
do these two things okay like I don't
think there's anything else that a
tenant can do that's bad apart from not
pay rent and trash the house like
there's nothing there's lots of stories
and ways that they could do these two
things but pretty much if you have a bad
tenant it's going to be because they're
not paying the rent on time or they're
damaging the house so that's kind of it
summarizes every bad tenant how do you
stop it happening references get a good
management company and reference for
tenants before they move in one of the
reasons why people have bad tenants
moving in the house is because what
happens is investor naive investor
doesn't know what they're doing
buys a house
and overestimates the rent that they'll
get in the house maybe they were sold
the property on false pretences by the
agent and they think they're gonna get a
thousand pound rent really the rents
just 800 so what happens is they put the
rent on for a thousand and and it's
empty and people like oh my gosh my
house is empty and because they're
stressed because it's empty we rather
than just reducing the rent to the
proper rent and doing their due
diligence properly in the first place
what they do is they just sit there
holding out worried and then a bad
tenant comes along and says I'll move in
tomorrow and I'll pay cash and then that
the investor is like dawn and let's the
tenant move in despite actually there
being a high-risk tenant that always
ends badly oh I've been there so that's
kind of the danger the slippery slope
but how do you how do you know if
they're not going to pay rent how do you
know if they're gonna trash the property
let's talk about not paying rent to
start with if a tenant has got a good
experience with a previous landlord
they're in a good job they passed the
affordability checks they passed the
credit checks then there's a very very
good chance that they're gonna pay you
rent on time so how do you know if how
do you know all that though you just
make sure that you've got a good manager
where you can get references off the off
those people and you usually the land
agent will tell you if there are
high-risk tenant and it's amazing how
many landlords just say oh it's okay
move them in because they're going to
move in next week and I just need a
tenant so just anything will rent out as
long as it's at the right price do you
need evidence figure out what the right
price is advertise it at the right price
hold out for a good 10 and how do you
make sure they're not going to trash the
property number one get a previous
landlord reference
now when I say previous landlord
reference what normally property
management companies do is they don't
get a previous level reference they call
it a previous Landman reference but they
get a current landlord reference because
if you think about it the house that
they're in currently that's not previous
that's current and the danger of that is
what happens is the current landlord
doesn't want the tenant in there because
the tenant is a
the tenant damages the house the tenant
has got children the color on the walls
is about 12 dogs and six cats that mess
the house up the tenant leaves the
windows open and then it gets steamy and
mold in the bathrooms the tenant is a
bad tenant that trashes the property
over time but the current landlord wants
the tenant to go okay so what the
current landlord does is the current
landlord says this pillar is fantastic
glowing reference why because they just
want them out of the house so what you
need to do is you need to go back to the
previous landlord because they've got no
agenda and say how was this cannon and
then you get the true answer another
thing you need to do is you need to get
a deposit make sure it's registered but
get a deposit that way if the tenant
does damage the property they'll pay at
least they'll pay up to the deposit
amount another thing you need to do gin
to get inventory so when the tenant
moves in get a breakdown of everything
in the house a check list and if there's
anything that's damaged or not in
brilliant repair write it down on the
inventory take pictures this is all
stuff that the property management
company will be able to do and nothing
that you can do to make sure they don't
trust the property is do regular
inspections so when the tenant moves in
three months after the tenant has been
living there get the management company
to go out and do an inspection on the
house to check that everything is okay
and the house has been looked after and
then every single six months get the
management company to go around the
property and have a look around the
management company will usually do all
of this stuff they'll do the checks
they'll collect the rent
they'll do the all this stuff and
they'll just take their percentage of
the rent and typically management
companies charge around about ten
percent of the rent and they if you get
the right management company will do all
of this talk for you they'll register
the deposit now make sure all the
legalities are taken care of there make
sure that they vet the tenants properly
they'll manage the tenant properly so
this is all the stuff that you need to
do to avoid bad tenants if you have been
unfortunate and you've got a really bad
tenant someone who's not paying rent or
someone that's damaging the property my
advice would be to get them out now
listen the tenants do have rights and I
think that's a good thing if you could
just say to a tenant because they paid
the rent a day late hey you're leaving
in 24 hours that would be a little bit
unfair
I don't know about you but even though
I've had times when I've actually didn't
you forgot to make a payment or have
been a little bit late and that's just
life however there are things in place
which protect you you also as the
landlord if a tenant isn't paying rent
if a tenant damaging the property as a
landlord you do have a right to put that
right and you do have a right to evict
the tenants so again a management
company should be able to do this for
you but I'm going to leave it in the
description below the name of a company
called evict them code at UK and if
you've got any issues with a tenant and
you like oh my gosh and you're pulling
your hair out and you struggle in and
you want to make sure that you give them
right notice that the right time to do
it properly I would highly recommend
speaking to someone from a victim doctor
at UK and they'll bill to make sure they
can take care of that and help you with
it so as a landlord the last thing I
want you to be doing or as an investor
is to be dealing with tenants and
running around and putting your hair out
that's why I say get a good management
company in place make sure that they
understand this video and they're doing
the right checks and they're doing the
right things to prevent again it gives
bad tenants if you do have a bad tenant
ask the management company to sort it
and if they aren't sorting your property
or they can't sort it speak to you a
victim coda UK and they will be able to
I hope that helps for anyone having bad
tenants if you haven't got any
properties yet make sure you put the
right tenant in the property so that it
truly is passive income and when you've
got a hundred houses one day you've got
a lot of passive income rather than one
hundred headaches what happens if the
tenants trashed the property watch this
video right here and know exactly what
to do if this happens I'd also suggest
if you want to listen in to a story by
Gareth he's one of my students check
this out
he had some problems with tenants you
might want to listen to his journey
whatever you do though you've got to
spend two days at the property investors
crash course free tickets on the house
baby and don't forget to subscribe